can you kind of take a couple minutes
and walk us through the entire process
i know you said felix called you you
said yes you signed the nda
you kind of went through the process of
that but then what happened from there
the day of talking to family preparation
concerns fears walk us through a little
bit yeah no problem
first off when you say like i'm the only
person who's done it this is true
uh travis pastrana jumped out uh without
a parachute but clipped into somebody
you know they've all landed with the
parachute this was the first time doing
it
without a without a parachute without
anything and coming all the way to the
net
um and i think that what that shows that
nobody has attempted it
it's interesting because from my
skydiver friends my peers i would say
my equals in skydiving um the respect
that
you get and like some people say it's
crazy it's stupid why would you do it
but to a person every single person's
come back to me
um saying that that moment that you step
out and that commitment and the
self-confidence to be able to make
something like that happen
is something that just doesn't come
along and i think that
doing it once i'm done you know i did it
one time that's good
and i think people really realized how
serious that was
but um going back to i get the call hey
can you do this how can we do it they
had an idea of a giant slide
landing on a giant half pipe in like the
grand canyon sliding it out
theoretically that makes sense to me you
match the wall with your body and you
come down you touch the wall and you
slide out like a big skateboard ramp i
just couldn't figure out how can you
test that
can you drop something in that net and
make it swoop out again i got a wife and
a son and
um i want to be here to talk about it
you know i wanted to see is there a way
i could do this
yeah it's not the flip of a coin i
really worked hard to make sure that yes
i'm the crazy guy that jumped out of
playing without a parachute but i also
wanted to show that you could do
something that seems impossible if you
go about it the right way
we made baby steps so came up with the
netting idea
to land in a giant almost like a circus
net um really strong netting
then um to slow it down we used air
cylinders big pistons
so when you hit the net it compressed
the air and it
pulled it out there was talk of bungee
cords and
all different kinds of things but the
only thing i could picture is wiley
coyote
getting a net and shooting back up in
the states
so we end up with this air system in
this net and then we want to know hey
can this work
you know like i want to see is this even
possible so we built a
half scale model um in a friend's yard
jim churchman the stunt coordinator down
in california
we started dropping uh punching bags
filled with weights
into this net and measuring the g forces
and we start to figure out wow we can
actually do this
so then we built a full-scale one a 100
feet by 100 feet
we took it out in the middle of the
desert we took a helicopter aaron
fitzgerald flies this dummy
up we called it a dummy um it was this
weight that matched my weight in the
same drag
and we started dropping it in the net
from lower and lower my wife and son
come out to watch and we're measuring
the g-forces and they
come out to check it out the very first
drop they take this thing up in the air
and they drop it it cuts through the net
like butter and smashes into the ground
right in front of my wife and son camera
crews are all film documentary they all
turn to my wife right right away and my
wife has a big smile on her face
and they're like oh luke you know what's
going on this is over we haven't even
gotten started they all think it's over
and my wife looked at me and the cameras
and she said well
i think it's great because now it's not
happening you know we're not doing this
thing
so for her she really didn't want it to
happen uh it wasn't so much she didn't
want to happen it was just she
understands the reality of how dangerous
she got it
yeah but when that didn't work she knows
i'm not gonna do it if that's how it
works
so in her mind okay this is done we're
not doing this thing we're gonna collect
a little paycheck and hang out and
that's that uh and then as the testing
started coming along
and we started we fixed the netting we
fixed the problem with how it ended up
going through the net
we get everything sorted out and then it
all starts to hit home and starts to get
real that you know
we're doing this you know and that's
when my wife and i have some
real talks about the possibilities that
could come from this you know we went
into this with our eyes open
we definitely were not uh everything's
rosy and there's no way anything bad can
happen
i think that the guys that go into big
stunts like this with that attitude
where nothing can happen to me
i think that they're naive and
irresponsible you know
we are taking a risk when you step off
and do something like that now i've
stacked the deck in my favor we've
calculated it
it's calculated risk it's not flip of a
coin fingers crossed maybe it'll work
it was very dialed in that we were
certain it was going to work i just had
to do my job
and hit that net that day and you know
we had those
long talks with the wife it was a real
deal
[Music]